The New
York Times obtaining
chilling posts,
it says are from the Idaho murder suspect
Brian Kabaka as a teenager.
Time sharing screengrabs of the post
without front in which coworker
reportedly says he feels no emotion,
a little remorse.
One says, quote, As I hug my family,
I look into their faces.
I see nothing.
It is like I am looking at a video game.
OUTFRONT now,
Nicholas Vogel
Burrows, the reporter
who broke this story.
And Nick,
I know that you identified
and have now read through
hundreds of messages
from about a decade of time that you say
were written by Koeberg or so.
This would go from the time
he was a teenager all the way until now.
Tell me more about what
stood out to you in these posts.
Yeah, so it begins
with these
posts on a forum website
when he's about 16 years old
and he's talking about feeling
a range of mental health conditions
or problems with his life.
He talks about not being able
to feel emotions,
feeling like he's
detached, from the world.
And as you mentioned, that
when he hugs his own family,
he sees nothing.
He also describes looking at his life
and going through the motions
like it's a video game,
and he's really hard on himself
saying he feels worthless, that he's
a jerk to people in his life
and doesn't feel bad about it afterwards.
He also talks particularly about his dad
saying he treats his dad like dirt
even though he thinks of him
as a good guy.
And it's it's this is all back
when he's in about high school in
his later teen years.
And what we know about
his life after that is that he ends up
becoming
addicted to heroin
around the time that he graduated
high school in 2013.
And he's in and out of rehab.
But then what's kind of interesting is
is after that it seems like his life
turns around somewhat.
He goes to community college
and gets start
studying psychology and starts
messaging other friends about saying he's
he's interested in studying
the minds of criminals.
It seems like he's found a passion
of some kind
in psychology and criminology.
Wow.
And then he ends up going
of course, as we
now to across the country
from Pennsylvania,
where he grew up to Washington state
last summer and starts a Ph.D.
program in criminology there.
So it's amazing to see this.
And you've had a chance
to read all through this,
which which has to be
difficult.
You say that one of his friends
told you
that coworker suffered
from a neurological condition
called a visual
snow, where people basically,
as you describe it, see scattered
dots like sort of static
on a on a television
to people of a certain age.
One of the posts you shared with us
says, and I quote,
What you shared with us
is as if the ringing in my ears
and the fuzz in my vision
is simply all the demons in my head
mocking me.
What else
do you know about the context there?
Yeah, the visual snow is a really
little understood condition.
It's like you said, it's
static in your vision,
like old television.
And it
there's really
the causes still not fully clear,
but it really can be debilitating
for some people.
You know, I want to be clear.
It's not a sign of mental illness
and it's not something
that anyone has said
could explain
these these heinous killings.
But it's something that
he complained a lot
about as a teenager, both to friends
and on these online posts.
And that was coupled with
his complaints about life in general.
All right.
Well, Nick, thank you very much.
I appreciate your sharing
your reporting with us
and some of those posts is disturbing
as they are as people
try to understand this.
Thank you.
And on the back of Nick's
reporting, let's now bring in Jim Fallon.
He's a neuroscientist
and professor of psychiatry
and human behavior at UC Irvine.
So, Jim, you know, you hear Nick,
The New York Times reporter
talking about Coburg are suffering
from a condition called visual snow
and the Times,
as he referenced
this with the initials V.
S in an online post
that says, when I get home,
I mean, to my family,
this started when voice did
I felt no emotion.
Is there anything
you can tell us about this
visual snow condition?
Well, the visual
snow is often associated with migraine.
And it's it's thought to be generated
by hyper stimulated neurons.
The base of the temporal lobe.
That's where visual processing,
a lot of visual processing occurs.
And so, yes, it's it's
debilitating and almost
nothing is known about it.
But it is a
syndrome
that you know, it's
you know,
you never hear about it
being associated with murder
or anything like that.
Although if you read the rest of his post
and it seems clear
that he's got
a depersonalization syndrome
and which is a dissociative disorder,
where you feel separated from yourself.
And is that when you're talking about,
as Nick was just saying,
you know,
sort of when he looks at the faces
of his family members,
he just says he feels nothing.
Is that that's what you're referring to?
Well, yes.
You know, you have
on the top of your head right here
in the spiritual parietal cortex.
You have a GPS system.
But what it does is it puts together
your whole world.
It tells you where your eyes are,
relationship to your head,
but relationship to the world.
And then it adds an emotion to that.
And all of that apparatus
seems to be damaged.
And so
he doesn't even connect with himself.
So he doesn't even have self empathy,
which is extraordinary.
All right.
And this lack of empathy
toward others in himself.
You often see it in psychopaths.
I'm not saying he's a psychopath,
but it's such a curious
combination of things.
But, you know, he was
a heroin addict
and the heroin can can trigger
this dissociation,
this depersonalization syndrome.
It's like you're living
in a dream where you're watching yourself
you can see this in schizophrenia
and schizoaffective disorder,
different psychiatric disorders
where people feel separated
from themselves.
You see in people who take hallucinogens.
Yes.
And they were they tried.
And so you sit in dream states,
we measure all sorts of dreams
or you see this.
And so anybody who's had
these strange dreams
where they're hanging over themselves
or an Anastasia.
And so we people have experiences,
but not all the time.
It's not they don't feel that
that it's occurring 100% of the time.
In his case,
it seems
and he's living this all the time,
like he's in a dream state
and a very disturbing,
very disturbing state.
Well, Jim, thank you very much.
He knows all the words.
He knows he knows the he studied this.
Right.
That and that,
I think, is the most bizarre part
about it. Right.
Is able
to make that connection and able to study
it all as well
and choose
that that entire path of learning.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate your time, Jim.